Let me show you something I saw the other
day.
This is the new Irish Prime Minister – the
Taoiseach
…trying to impress his Canadian colleague
on a state visit.
Anything catch your attention?
That made me think: 'We must talk about socks.'
So much goes wrong
…in that department.
You see socks are not there to keep your feet
warm.
They're there to keep your legs out of sight.
Rule number one:
Your socks must be long enough.
Even when you're sitting down
…your bare legs can NEVER be exposed.
Rule number two – color.
Your socks should match your trousers.
Not your shoes.
Number three: Keep it simple.
Plain is best.
Striped Dotted Checked
Also possible.
Even bright, garish colors can work.
But that's pretty advanced stuff.
Which brings me to rule number four.
Novelty socks.
You know.
Mickey Mouse.
Dollar signs.
National flags.
The funny stuff.
What Mum gave you for Christmas
…in 1995.
Don't do it.
Ever.
Period.
'But what' – I hear you cry
…'what about Batman socks?'
And yes, of course, that's the exception.
Batman socks are OK.
But only if you actually are…
Batman.
Oh, you're not Batman?
Rule number four applies.